[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 12 décembre
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité locale entre deux
tours de la présidentielle ratée
tensions en interne défections au sein
du groupe au conseil régional
d'ile-de-france le front national
traverse une période difficile cette
semaine la fédération des yvelines
organisé sa soirée de noël à versailles
en présence de david rachline l'occasion
d'évoquer la reconstruction du parti
il est récompensé pour son action contre
les maladies mentales jouer le doré a
reçu aujourd'hui à paris le prix à
marcel dassault à 2017 ce directeur de
recherche à l'inra jouy en josas mène
des travaux sur la microbiologie
explication dans ce journal
et puis c'est tout frais parly 2 compte
une nouvelle extension c'est la fin de
plusieurs années de travaux de
modernisation pour le centre commercial
yvelinois son directeur jonathan tout le
monde est notre invité elle nous
parlerons également avec lui de la
période des fêtes à parly 2 elle lundi
soir donc le front national des yvelines
tenait sa soirée de noël dans un
restaurant de versailles dans un
contexte est difficile la fédération
départementale recevait david rachline
maire de fréjus et directeur de la
communication du fn est l'occasion pour
lui et ses équipes d'évoquer le nouveau
souffle qu'il souhaite donner au parti
les arrêts ge et nicolas bendriss débat
de l'entre-deux-tours qualifié de rater
départ de florian philippot et la sphère
des assistants eurodéputés le front
national est en pleine tourmente depuis
les élections présidentielles de mai
dernier
son maître mot aujourd'hui
reconstruction nos adhérents sont en
attente en attente de notre fondation et
veulent savoir ce que ça va comporter
exactement
quel est notre avenir à court terme à
moyen terme et j'espère alors que leur
apporter un certain nombre de réponses à
ça car oui nous sommes en pleine
refondation aux fondations qui a été
souhaité par marine et qu'elle met en
oeuvre progressivement jusqu'au congrès
en mars nous reconquête des militants
s'opère à présent à l'échelle nationale
mais aussi et surtout auprès des
départements et des municipalités
l'objectif regagner une unité je pense
qu'il faut absolument mettre en valeur
nos équipes municipales en cercle à
l'immense chance d'avoir un maire front
national avec maintenant que la ville
est par ailleurs des équipes aussi dans
l'opposition qui sont qui veille qui
veille à la démocratie à la bonne
gestion de local est une équipe forte
comme celles des mureaux qu'on n'entend
pas souvent donné la parole aux
militants pour mieux les connaître c'est
le souhait également du parti le 14
novembre dernier un questionnaire a été
lancé auprès des adhérents
on est vraiment dans la refondation
c'est des ronces et qu'on est dans une
période sans élection proche donc de
restructuration des coûte surtout les
électeurs des militants de ces deux
de savoir ce qui a déçu ce qu'ils
attendent les nombreux départs au sein
du fn dans les yvelines françois simeoni
ancien président yves binois du fn puis
yasmine menzel matt ancien conseiller
régional fragilise le parti la récente
élection de laurent wauquiez à la
présidence des républicains ne semblent
pas quant à elle les inquiéter moments
difficiles pour le front national en
ile-de-france la été évoqué trois élus
dont l'yvelinois zayas mines benzema qui
ont quitté récemment le groupe fn au
conseil régional
le front national qui a rappelé vous en
2014 avait fait une percée à
mantes-la-ville premières communes
d'ile-de-france à devenir frontiste avec
l'élection de cyril note quatre
représentants de la communauté musulmane
de mantes la ville sont jugés à partir
d'aujourd'hui au tribunal correctionnel
de versailles
accusé d'avoir tenté de répertorier les
musulmans du territoire avec le but lors
de ces municipales de les inciter à
voter pour la maire sortante ps de
l'époque monique brochot son territoire
comprend une grande partie de versailles
mis aussi à l'est ville de montigny le
bretonneux et de guyancourt le député
les rênes de la première circonscription
des yvelines didier baichère tenait une
réunion publique
c'était la semaine dernière au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
six mois après son élection le
parlementaire a dressé son bilan
personnel et mais aussi celui de
l'action du gouvernement
il a été question notamment du budget du
plan étudiants échanger pédagogie
nécessaire aux yeux de l'élu sur des
sujets qu'ils avancent vite
propos recueillis par nicolas kirilow
liszt et c'est important de se
confronter avec les habitants de la
circonscription pour voir comment eux
ils percevaient l'ensemble de ces
changements et le rythme des
transformations
c'est aussi un moment de pédagogie pour
expliquer pourquoi on a voulu un budget
qui à la fois très social mais aussi
très réaliste
il faut que les entreprises puissent
investir recruter et en même temps on a
traité les salariés avec du gain de
pouvoir d'achat
et ça c'est important de voir si les
habitants de la circonscription que ce
soit à guyancourt à montigny ou à
versailles ont bien compris ce qu'on
voulait faire dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui 2150 enfants sont prises en
charge par la protection de l'enfance 85
millions d'euros par ans consacré
d'ailleurs à cette part à cette mission
par le conseil départemental
hier une réunion sur le sujet se
déroulait à plaisir à destination des
accueils de loisirs mais aussi des
professionnels de l'éducation sur place
mélanie poker ils sont professeurs
animateurs aux responsables
d'établissements et parfois témoins de
situations préoccupantes
87 d'entre elles ont été signalés en
2017 sur le secteur plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux en fait sur
des problématiques de défaut de soins
sur des problématiques de famille
dépassée par ce qui se passe ou en tout
cas complètement débordés par leur vie
professionnelle et leur vie familiale et
ça peut avoir des retentissements
important sur sur la situation avec les
enfants ça peut être des conflits très
important avec des adolescents ça peut
être des choses extrêmement variés des
conflits familiaux auxquels les enfants
assistent au quotidien ce lundi la ville
de plaisir et le département des
yvelines proposer nos réunions
d'information une initiative de la
mairie dans le projet ville solidarité
lancée en 2015 la protection de
l'enfance comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour être plus efficient
c'est à dire que les services puissent
se parler entre eux et travailler entre
eux pour pouvoir rendre un service
rapide aux familles
le problème ce n'est pas de faire des
réunions pour faire des réunions c'est
de mettre en place de véritables outils
pour pouvoir le faire le mieux possible
67 enfants sont placés sur le secteur
une trentaine de travailleurs sociaux de
l'enfance s'occupe de saint quentin en
yvelines
les échanges à aiguille en cours vont se
renforcer avec la mise en place dans la
ville d'une nouvelle stratégie
territoriale de sécurité de prévention
de la délinquance 40 partenaires
signataires parmi lesquels le préfet des
yvelines le procureur de la république
l'académie de versailles le département
et saint quentin en yvelines
l'idée de favoriser la synergie des
acteurs de terrain et des groupes de
travail ont été constitués pour mener
des actions concrètes autour de trois
axes écouter tout le monde va travailler
ensemble à partir d'un certain nombre
d'actes qui ont été déterminés c'est à
dire se préoccuper des jeunes échanger
sur des situations concrètes prévention
effectivement de la délinquance donc à
guyancourt par exemple nous on a ouvert
un poste d'éducateur spécialisé
on accueille aussi à des mineurs et des
majeurs dans le cadre des tiges et puis
on a un autre axe aussi qui est
important pour nous c'est la prévention
des violences faites aux femmes et
intrafamiliales et puis aussi tout ce
qui est autour de la tranquillité
publique
donc nous on a on va perdurer les liens
que l'on a avec nos bailleurs et puis on
va mettre aussi des actions de
sensibilisation avec les jeunes autour
effectivement la tranquillité du niqab
santé à présent avec un ebe noir
récompensée pour ses travaux sur la
microbiologie joue elle dort et
directeur de recherche à l'inra à jouy
en josas depuis 34 ans il a reçu cet
après midi le prix marcel dassault 2017
pour la recherche sur les maladies
mentales
joël doré travaille sur un projet pour
comprendre les liens entre troubles de
l'intestin et autisme les précisions
avec l'intéressé au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude et nicolas
kirillovitch chercheur à l'inra depuis
1983 basée dans les yvelines à jouy en
josas joël doré est le lauréat 2010 est
du prix marcel dassault pour les
recherches sur les maladies rares un
prix qui récompense son projet intitulé
assez long assez complexe intitulé la
micro bio tout le microbiote intestinal
chez les personnes avec trouble du
spectre de l'autisme un lien entre
l'inflammation et les troubles digestifs
alors je vais me tourner vers vous joël
doré est ce que vous pouvez un petit peu
vulgariser votre projet en quoi il
consiste concrètement sur quoi vous vous
travaillez à l'inra bien sûr alors on a
depuis longtemps maintenant des travaux
de recherche qui porte sur la relation
entre le microbiote intestinal et
l'humain dans le contexte de la santé
mais également dans des contexte de
pathologie et on a pu grâce à ces
travaux documenté l'altération de
ce qu'on va appeler la symbiose la
relation normale entre l'homme et ses
microbes dans les grandes pathologies de
sociétés modernes qui sont des maladies
souvent avec une composante
inflammatoire une altération de défense
naturelle et dans ces pathologies ce que
l'on sait c'est qu'elle augmente en
proportion en incidence depuis
maintenant 60 ans l'après guerre de
façon apparemment incontrôlés au sens où
finalement elles ne peuvent pas être
expliquées par une altération de la
génétique humaine
donc elles sont sous le contrôle de
paramètres dans l'environnement et
notamment d'une altération de du
microbiote intestinal
ce que le projet propose en fait en
l'occurrence et d'explorer l'importance
de la relation entre le microbiote
intestinal et le patient dans le
contexte des troubles du spectre de
l'autisme
ce qui veut dire qu'on pourrait on
pourrait éventuellement imaginer qu'il y
a un lien entre les deux quelle serait
la cause quel serait l'effet du coup
alors ce qu'on peu documenté aujourd'hui
à travers la littérature scientifique
assez nourris c'est que il ya
effectivement de nombreux cas où la
littérature scientifique rapporte une
altération du microbiote intestinal
chez les patients autistes les enfants
ou les adultes en fait autistes et on
peut penser aujourd'hui que cette
altération est un facteur aggravant d'un
contexte d'inflammation qui finalement
relie assez nettement pour ce que nous
dit la science
l'altération au niveau intestinal et la
signalisation au niveau du cerveau on a
les travaux sur l'animal et des travaux
sur l'homme qui documentent ses
observations aujourd'hui donc votre
objectif à vous avec ce projet
aujourd'hui c'est ce n'est pas forcément
de guérir c'est d'améliorer
éventuellement la vie des patients c'est
le premier objectif de votre projet là
c'est bien c'est important de le
mentionner de cette façon là
effectivement l'objet du projet est de
mieux documenter mieux caractériser la
relation entre le patient et son micro
butt
dans le contexte de des troubles du
spectre de l'autisme avec notamment un
accent mis
sur cette relation altéré qui fait que
plus de la moitié des patients ont des
symptômes gastro-intestinaux et donc on
va essayer documenté très finement la
relation entre le microbiote
l'inflammation et les symptômes gastro
intestinaux chez les patients que l'on
peut percevoir comme une piste possible
de construction d'innovation en termes
de stratification et de suivi des
patients mieux caractériser des patients
c'est mieux adapter le traitement
possible en fait et en termes de
thérapeutique pour a minima résoudre les
symptômes gastro-intestinaux qui sont
aussi des problèmes de vie quotidienne
en fait pour les patients et leurs
familles
et puis sur cette base là peut être
positionné les patients dans un contexte
plus favorable pour la prise en charge
clinique classique aujourd'hui alors ce
prix marcel dassault ses trois cent
mille euros je crois 245 milles euros
pour votre projet deux cent quarante
cinq mille euros ça va vous permettre de
faire quoi concrètement est ce que c'est
c'est pour le long terme
ou est-ce que ça va très vite dans ce
genre de recherche et que 245 milles
euros ça va pouvoir juste à court terme
vous aider en fait on met en oeuvre des
outils qui sont les plus performants
aujourd'hui pour la caractérisation du
microbiote intestinal
et puis on va aussi inclure des patients
donc 150 patients autiste asperger 50
individus contrôle qu'on va caractériser
de façon exhaustive à la fois au plan
clinique pour les patients mais aussi au
plan de la physiologie de la nutrition
du microbiote intestinal bien sûr avec
des outils qui sont performants mais
également cher est de toute façon les
essais cliniques sont des essais qui
sont assez coûteux j'en profite pour
indiquer également qu'on va en plus de
cet essai réalisé chez le patient et
chez l'homme
donc réalisé un travail sur l'animal qui
a vocation à montrer que l'on peut par
transfert de microbiote celle des
modèles animaux qui sont étudiées
l'inra montrer qu on a une relation
effectivement un lien potentiel de
causalité entre l'altération du
microbiote et les symptômes
gastro-intestinaux et puis pour bien
comprendre des ponts conclure pour bien
comprendre l'enjeu de ce de ce projet
les troubles aujourd'hui du spectre de
l'autisme toucherait en france près de
1% de la population ce nombre-là ne
cesse d'augmenter et il n'existe
aujourd'hui aucun traitement curatif
merci pour ces précisions je l'adoré
merci à vous eux aussi ont été
récompensés 200 étudiants de l'ufr de
sciences sociales de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines ont
reçu leur diplôme première cérémonie du
genre organisée en fin de semaine
dernière sur le site de guyancourt
l'occasion de marquer la fin d'un cycle
passé à l'université pour les étudiants
de licence générale et professionnelle
ainsi que pour les masters interview
collectées par nicolas qui réjouissent
c'est l'occasion pour nous d'avoir un
tout de suite après leur diplomation
d'avoir tout de suite une première
impression sur finalement comment dans
leur poursuite d'études pour ceux qui
poursuivent leurs études ou leur
insertion
comment il comme ils se sentent et est
ce que la formation il arrive
effectivement à bien
faire le lien et à l'utiliser dans le
cadre de leur nouvelle activité
nous vous en avons parlé dans le 7-8
journal le centre commercial parly 2 au
chesnay a inauguré tout récemment sa
nouvelle extension
un passage qui permet aux clients de
circuler plus facilement dans l'enceinte
16 boutiques et qui ouvrait des
enseignes historiques qui se réinvente
bonsoir jonathan tout le monde
bon ça vous êtes le directeur de parly 2
l'inauguration de cette nouvelle
extension c'était le 29 novembre
finalement un renouveau pour le centre
commercial qui a débuté depuis 2010 200
millions d'euros qui ont été investis et
c'est la fin oui d'une longue phase de
travaux on peut lire pour le centre
commercial
effectivement mercredi 29 novembre nous
avons célébré à la fin de cette dernière
tranche de travaux les plus lourds les
plus conséquents mais qui s'inscrivait
dans un programme beaucoup plus longs
qui ont démarré qui a démarré en 2010
donc en reprenant la chronologie de ces
programmes
on a d'abord eu la rénovation d'une
partie du centre en 2010-2011 en 2012
2013 on a créé un nouvel accès derrière
le centre pour mieux répartir les flux
et mieux reggae les arrières du centre
elle décongestionner elle sont revues du
chéné moi quand je suis arrivé début
on s'est attaché à rénover l'extension
est créée en 1987 pour la mettre en
cohérence avec l'esprit vraiment sixty
chic élégant du centre commercial parce
que si on revient sur l'historique
il ya eu effectivement une rénovation
une expansion 87 et de puis plus grand
chose
exactement donc avait quelque chose à
faire est donc à peine cette rénovation
1900 cas de 1987 achevée on a commencé
cette extension de mars 2016 à novembre
2017 qui visait à faire se connecter à
faire se rencontrer deux partis du
centre qui était un petit peu en
cul-de-sac la zone du bhv de monoprix la
zone de la fnac ca
donc on a inséré une brique à la place
des parkings et donc on a créé cette
boucle de circulation qui est bien plus
bien plus aisé et d'ailleurs c'est le
principal retour des clients c'est on
circule beaucoup mieux dans votre centre
commercial et c'est beaucoup plus
agréable et on a profité effectivement
pour raynaud si la totalité des façades
extérieures
douze mille mètres carrés de façade et
façades en fait de l'ensemble immobilier
mais aussi des parkings et l'autre
grande nouvelle qui attendait des
clients et les commerçants s'étaient la
réouverture des accès et des parkings
et donc voilà donc on est très contents
de la fin de cette opération
et pourquoi ce renouveau est est il
primordial pour parler d'eux à la fois
pour offrir une offre commerciale
supplémentaire on oeuvre 16 en offre 16
nouvelles boutiques dont deux très beaux
noms comme job pour ces petites doudoune
ultralégère bensimon ateliers de famille
new balance armani exchange bientôt est
ouverte sur des mâts et uniqlo et à
proximité
la proximité aussi l'ouverture enfin la
réouverture d'une offre de jouer avec la
grande récré maison du monde qu'il faut
six sa grande entrée à parly 2 et la
réouverture de monoprix qui s'est
étendue sur 2000 mètres carrés dans un
dernier concept voilà et donc il était
important de réinsuffler un petit peu de
modernité de cohérence dans ses
différentes parties du centre qui
s'était construit au fur et à mesure des
années sans forcément beaucoup de
cohérence
alors si nouvelle extension qui est
juste avant qui a été fait juste avant
le grand rush
l'inauguration s'est déroulée juste
avant le grand rush de décembre et des
fêtes de fin d'année est ce qu'il y ait
une organisation particulière pour
parler d'eux à ce moment là pour cette
période des fêtes oui les chiffres ont
tendance à montrer que 30 à 40% de
l'activité d'une enseigne se fait à
partir du 15 novembre
mais ça représente effectivement il ya
un enjeu colossal tout d'abord dans
l'enseigne
il ya probablement un renfort de
l'équipe qui se met en place d
approvisionnement supplémentaire donc
tout un flux logistiques a organisé et
qui impacte aussi le centre et ses
abords d'accord bien sûr du
merchandising une décoration ça c'est la
partie plutôt enseignes et le centre se
mobilisent aussi pour accompagner les
clients et les commerçants nous
vigipirate bien entendu s'adapte on
renforce nos dispositifs sur centrée sur
les abords en partenariat avec les
forces de police et bien évidemment
sécurité renforcée du cours exactement
une décoration noël qui arrive vers le
15 novembre pour créer cette féerie
c'est important de se sentir bien d'être
dans un esprit familial décontractée
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on attache à
faire parler d'eux et puis on offre
aussi des animations par exemple on nous
on a un très grand calendrier de l'avent
ou on gagne systématiquement une
dotation qui a offert par une enseigne
donc c'est un moment récréatif pour le
client il gagne à tous les coups et cela
donne de la visite à une enseigne par
exemple on a des grooms pour aider nos
clients à faire les parcours centre de
shopping et parking on a aussi
un père noël bien entendu les huées et
des décorations de noël tout à fait
gigantesque avec un sapin de 12 mètres
de haut un ours un ours en peluche
géante côté de chez truffaut
tout est fait pour créer un petit peu
l'émotion et
je pense que c'est important de
c'est quand même des moments de shopping
des moments d'émotion des moments
plaisants et on essaye de porter un peu
de féerie dans ce secteur évidemment on
peut le dire un double enjeu de faire
cette inauguration de la rénovation
juste avant les périodes des fêtes
c'était voulu
bien entendu il était important de tenir
un planning serré pour pour offrir des
fêtes à nos clients et à nos commerçants
tout à fait dernière thématique je
voulais aborder avec vous il ya cette
phase de travaux terminés enfin pas tout
à fait puisque le dernier chantier en
cours c'est la construction d'un
multiplexe ugc de 12 salles dont 2500
fauteuil ça ouvrira ouverture prévue en
2019 important mais qui est ce multiplex
pour la notoriété du centre commercial
très important cette offre loisirs
nous avions un cinéma qui a fermé en
juin 2014
cinq salles ce qui m'a un petit peu
vieillissant mais historique apprécié là
on a réussi donc à obtenir toutes les
autorisations nécessaires auprès
notamment des autorités compétentes
pardon pour ouvrir mi 2010 9,1 grands
multiplexes 2
douze salles totalisant 2000 200 sièges
avec l'opérateur juger c'est ciné cité
dont on est ravis qu'ils leur offrent
eux viennent puisque en fait c'est un
flux très complémentaires par rapport au
shopping un peu classique c'est 6 nov
qu'il ya plus tôt en soirée sur des flux
et des créneaux horaires un petit peu
différent et c'est une attente très très
forte qu'on sent prêt de tous les
habitants de la zone et de nos visiteurs
ça sera ma dernière question à ce cinéma
ugc arrive dans une eau à dire une offre
assez pléthorique de cinéma dans les
yvelines ya le multiplex haussier à
saint quentin en yvelines
ugc des multiplexes prévu à maurepas à
plaisir pour 2019 c'est un peu plus loin
en terme de kilomètres
vous n'avez pas peur sur la
fréquentation que l or l empathie ce
finalement cette présentation non
l'offre à proximité c'est celle de
versailles le roxana cyrano mais qui
sont plutôt sur dollar est décédé choses
un peu plus un peu plus pointu un peu
plus spécialisés facile offre
complémentaire on est vraiment sur une
offre grand public
donc voilà donc dans un rayon de 0 15
minutes on sera le seul la seule offre
de ceux de ce type là multiplex grand
public voilà donc on est très très
contents de cette ouverture encore une
fois été 2019
merci et jonathan tout le monde apprécie
avec nouveau directeur de parly 2 et
pour plus d'informations sur le centre
commercial les différents horaires
d'ouverture vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
ça sera notre dernier à ce sujet comme
chaque mardi le portrait de la rédaction
consacré à une personnalité du
territoire il est sans conteste l'un des
yvelinois de l'année a dit lahm ou mady
a conservé à sa ceinture européenne de
boxe le 11 novembre dernier au vélodrome
à national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et avant de se tourner vers le
championnat du monde le sportif de la
team farruggia s'adonne à une autre
carrière sont notre carrière celle
d'agents de la ville d'elancourt et les
images de ce sujet sont signées nicolas
kirilow liszt et lis calais mais d'euros
il y a le boxeur mais aussi l'animateur
deux facettes qui constitue a dit la
môme a dit l'athlète vous le connaissez
sans doute champion d'europe des poids
super-moyens ceinture que l'élan
courtois a conservé en battant ans
christopher est brassée à l'issue des
douze secondes c'était à domicile lors
du mail et 24 ou vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et encore
merci pour ceux qui me soutiennent une
ceinture européenne conquise pour la
première fois en 2015 face à l'espanyol
mariano hilario adila à mohammadia alors
34 ans succès obtenu sur le tard certes
mais le boxeur vise toujours plus haut
ce qui a fait la peut-être la différence
sur ce combat c'était peut-être la
détermination
voilà je sais pourquoi j'y suis allé je
voulais cette ceinture c'est un objectif
que je voulais atteindre de la
détermination il en a fallu aux sportifs
un an plus tard nous sommes en 2016
adila mohammadi remet en jeu son titre
face à l'anglais kaloum smith à
liverpool
un combat qui tourne mal dès le premier
round elle
benoît tente sa chance mais vite dépassé
par son adversaire et larbitre contraint
d'arrêter le match
après cette défaite on dit alors le
boxeur fini c'est mal le connaître
adila se remet vite en selle avec l'aide
de la team farrugia et du promoteur
malamine koné n'ont alors ma carrière
n'est pas terminée
il faut le savoir elle n'est pas terminé
ma carrière je suis pas un rêveur voilà
rêver c'est quand on dort nord ont fait
pas grand chose donc moi je suis
vraiment plus qu'elle tient qui a qui a
qui a des objectifs
voilà et mon but c'est de les atteindre
au printemps dernier le compétiteur au
conquiert déjà sa ceinture européenne
d'un an après l'avoir perdue et conserve
donc son titre en novembre face à
christopher rebrassé à 37 ans a dit là à
mohammadi se laisse encore du temps pour
être challenger d'une ceinture mondiale
en attendant quand il n'est pas à
l'entraînement ou sur les rings a dit
labeaume a dit consacrent du temps à son
autre vie celle d'agents de la ville
d'elancourt un travail auprès des
enfants de l'école willy brandt comme ce
jour là avec des activités organisées au
complexe sportif de l'europe
hélas de la boxe semble se muer
parfaitement dans la peau d'animateur
c'est un beau matin il travaille bien il
me fait rigoler
les gentilles fées début moi je pensais
que c'était un simple animateur et comme
mes parents m'ont dit quand il est passé
à la télé ça m'a surpris car grand bruit
boxer et il est très gentil directeur de
centre de loisirs à son arrivée et long
cours
adila est re devenu ensuite animateurs
avec des échéances sportives de plus en
plus importante
il doit composer avec un emploi du temps
très chargé mais effectue tout de même
un service de 35 heures par semaine pour
la mairie yvelinoise ceci me coupure un
coupure par rapport à ce que je peux
faire le soir j'ai notre vie aussi dans
cette cette petite différence le boxeur
finalement qui n'est pas si brut que sa
vie qui finalement il est il et il est
avec les enfants aussi un rapport humain
qui est qui fait que ça me plait quoi a
dit la môme attiva à rentrer très
prochainement dans une nouvelle phase de
préparation travailler dur pour
atteindre son prochain objectif monter
sur le toit du monde voilà c'est la fin
de feu 7,8 journal reportages et replay
retrouver sur notre application mobile
est également un autre site internet
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]